hey 42 here a young Julius Caesar was
travelling across the Aegean Sea when he
was kidnapped by silicium Pirates the
Pirates demanded a ransom of 20 talents
of silver for his release worth about
half a million pounds in today's money
but Caesar was insulted and he demanded
that they raise his ransom to fifty
talents which they did the entire time
he was held captive
Julius refused to accept that he was a
prisoner and instead acted as though he
was in charge and the crew were his
subordinates Caesar would order them
around from within his cell and demand
things such as no noise to be made on
musical instruments to be played whilst
he is sleeping he spent most of his time
in captivity writing poems and speeches
and then demanding that the Pirates
listen to him recite them which
strangely they did Caesar managed to
make friends with the Pirates and over
time they grew to like him and even
respect him as their superior he will
play games and drink with his captors
and participated in their daily
exercises he was given the freedom to do
whatever he liked and bought the ship
and even to leave the ship and roam free
when they docked at islands like some
kind of free-range chicken Caesar but
Caesar hadn't gotten Stockholm Syndrome
far from it if anything he had given his
captors reverse Stockholm Syndrome
all the while Caesar didn't quite
appreciate being held prisoner and he
openly told his captors that after his
ransom had been paid he would hunt them
all down and have them crucified they
obviously thought he was both crazy
and joking because after Caesars ransom
was paid and he was released he did come
back for a small fleet that he had
raised himself and found his captors
exactly where they had left
and just like he had promised he
captured them all took back his 50
talents of silver and crucified each and
every one of them he must have grown
some fun this for his captors though as
he did slit their fruit before
crucifying them to save them any
suffering upon the crucifix the Golden
Age of piracy began in 1650 and waged
for almost 100 years the seas were full
to the brim of Buccaneers privateers
Corsairs and good old swashbuckling
treasure hunting pirates so what caused
pirates to exist in the first place skip
back a couple of decades to the 1630s
and England were hiring privateers
basically official and fully legal
pirates to raid Spanish treasure fleets
and take over treasure ports such as the
famous Portobello one prolific group of
these state-sponsored band of privateers
was led by the infamous Sir Henry Morgan
from Wales after pillaging and
plundering many large Spanish treasure
ports around Panama and bringing the
gold back to England
king charles ii knighted henry morgan
for basically slaughtering and torturing
thousands of Spanish and innocent
civilians but heigh-ho he provided
bountiful quantities of gold and silver
so a knighthood it would be all is
private even good skirmishing over
control of mineral-rich islands and
ports around the caribbean eventually
led to an all-out war between nations
for control of the region the English
the Dutch - Spanish French and Danes
engaged in a war known as Queen Anne's
war for 11 years donations battles it
out on the high seas Britain eventually
won the war but after the conflict had
died down many peaceful trade deals were
struck between the rival nations and one
of history's most profitable trade
triangles was established sugar and
tobacco were sent from the Caribbean to
Europe
manufactured goods such as guns were
sent to Africa and then African slaves
were taken to North and South America so
to maintain peace and loss protects the
integrity of this highly valuable trade
route the British made all piracy
illegal and set out to eradicate it any
pirates court would be hanged and
displayed in the town's Harbor so that
nearby and visiting pirates could see
what the consequences of their actions
could be but despite the British and
every other nations efforts to eradicate
the very profession that they have
supported in the first place as it
usually does
quite the opposite happens over the next
100 years
piracy would be at its highest rate in
all of history as the world enters the
Golden Age of piracy you see during
queen anne's walk thousands of soldiers
from all five nations had over a decade
of practice fighting at sea learning all
the necessary skills to be really
effective pirates but when the war ended
all of these soldiers were out of a job
overnight with nowhere else to find work
the majority of them turned to piracy
and a life on the high seas as a way to
make ends meet and so a huge influx of
pirates were unleashed upon the
Caribbean overnight but among these
ex-soldiers was one man so fierce so
unstoppable a man that struck so much
fear into the hearts and minds of his
foes that room was portrayed him as the
very devil himself
the Spanish called him el gran Diablo
the great devil some say that any man
who saw his ship on the horizon wouldn't
live to tell the tale but then where did
the rumors come from I wonder his name
was Edward Teach but he was far better
known as Blackbeard after the war he
gathered together a crew in the pirate
Haven of Nassau and he set out to steal
ships treasure and strengthen his crew
early on his voyages he captured a huge
French merchant ship he attached 40
cannons to it and renamed it Queen
Anne's Revenge adorning it with his
signature flag a horn skeleton spearing
a heart it was one of the largest and
most powerful warships in the Caribbean
he then terrorized the Seas for two
years which for a pirate's isn't so bad
during these years he made an absolute
fortune at sea Blackbeard was an
absolute master of fear
unlike most drunken vagabonds that took
to piracy Blackbeard was highly
intelligent and he understood the human
condition better than most his primary
weapon was intimidation and fear he
would stick to fuses in his big black
beard and set them alight before
attacking another ship this would emit a
cloud of smoke that would engulf his
face with his large piercing eyes and
scruffy beard and hair it was very easy
to see why most ships just chose to
surrender it the very sight of him
Blackbeard met his end like a true
pirate the British eventually grew tired
of his escapades and they sent out a
Royal Navy fleet to capture Blackbeard
dead or alive Blackbeard was outnumbered
and was killed whilst fighting with all
his might the British sailed back of
Blackbeard's head mounted at the tip of
the ship's bow spirit Blackbeard has
since enjoyed a fierce reputation within
history and popular fiction and whilst
he is the most infamous figure from the
Golden Age of piracy he was far from the
most successful and arguably not the
most badass
that's honor goes to a female Chinese
pirate who ruled the Seven Seas with an
iron grip and a tenacity that history's
most infamous dictators would be proud
of introducing Shing she she was born in
1775 and in her early 20s she was a
Humboldt prostitute but at 26 she
married zengi a notorious pirate who ran
one of the most powerful
fleets in the region the red flag fleet
which was essentially a coalition
between some of China's most powerful
pirate fleets but in 1807
she's husband Zheng Yi died during a
storm in Vietnam although there was some
suspicion that she may or may not have
murdered him
Ching she saw her opportunity and
quickly started to be friends and make
connections with the most powerful
members of the red flag fleet she
orchestrated all sorts of underhanded
deals of the goal of gaining support for
her leadership being a woman she was
surely fighting an uphill battle but her
hard work paid off and the crew voted
her in as their new captain but she knew
very well being a female pirate she
would never be taken quite as serious as
the former captain her now deceased
husband she suspected that sooner or
later the entirely male membership of
the red flag fleet over 20,000 pirates
would grow tired of being ordered around
by a woman and seek to disenfranchise
her leadership so she made sure there
would be never
any chance of that happening and she
knew exactly what to take she wrote a
code of law a long list of crimes and
their associated punishments and boy
were they strict if any crew members
disobeyed orders they would be
decapitated on the spot and if anyone
gave orders to another person that
didn't come directly from Ching she
herself they would be decapitated on the
spot if a member of crew raped a female
captive he would be decapitated but if
he had consensual sex with the captive
they would both be decapitated in fact
under her command male crew members were
only allowed to be intimate with a woman
if he had first paid for her and then
married her which is a really strange
way of looking at things speaking of
buying wives as we often do on
according to she's code of laws when new
female captives are acquired from
captured ships the ugly ones are to be
released and the most attractive females
were allowed to be purchased by the crew
but her totally bizarre set of rules did
create a ruthless efficiency among her
crew and earned her respect kingship has
often been called the most successful
pirate who ever lived and there's no
doubting that at her prime she commanded
an ax murder of over 80,000 pirates and
1800 ships that's just outrageous
especially when compared to Blackbeard
who commanded just four ships
and 300 men no foe ever faced
[ __ ] she's huge pirate army and lived
to tell the tale using a combination of
ruthless discipline efficiency and sheer
numbers her naval army was absolutely
formidable she had spies all over the
mainland as well and she forced farmers
to pay her taxes she basically
controlled the seas around Southeast
Asia any merchant vessel entering the
waters within her Dominion would have to
pay a protection fee to Qing shape if
they didn't then she set her pirates
loose on their ship she put an end to
her reign of terror the Shing Dynasty
itself at the order of the Emperor sent
out China's Imperial fleets to try and
put a stop to her they were
embarrassingly unsuccessful so the
Emperor instead took to England and
Portugal for help who at the time had
the two strongest navies in the world he
begged them to help him eradicate this
unstoppable pirate woman and her
ever-growing army so England and
Portugal did both send out modest fleets
to wage war against Ching she guess what
did they fails
but luckily for the Emperor of China she
eventually grew weary of a life of
piracy and made a deal with the Ching
dynasty that she could retire with
impunity all her past crimes were
forgiven and she got to keep all the
stolen wealth that she had accumulated
under top it all off she would be given
noble status in China which at the time
meant she were immune to a whole bunch
of laws she set up and ran a brothel and
in and she lived out the rest of her
days in peace in rural China making this
incredible and frankly terrifying woman
not only the most successful pirate in
all of history but also one of the very
few that didn't end up being hung for
their crimes or killed in battle
piracy may be an unsavory profession but
you've got to take your hat off to Ching
Shi thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video then please click here to
support me on patreon and if you haven't
already don't forget to subscribe